I hope that your wife gets harassed more at work, okay? Holy
She's like totally psyched that people are doxing Dan's family.
That's crazy. By the way, I think this might be the one line.
This may be the one line that Destiny might go, "Oh, actually
you got to go." I'm not joking. Oh, he called me a Yeah, of course
I don't want to feel bad for him anymore. Yeah, or for his wife,
or for his kids. What the First of all, I hope they get harassed
more.
Yeah, I hope I hope he gets doxxed, I hope he gets swatted. Yeah,
I don't care Like maybe they're only on Kick or something, but
this is totally termination worthy. This is crazy to openly call
for swatting somebody and not just them, but their family and
kids. Dox and swat them. That's crazy. >> He went there.
Yeah, of course.
So, Food Slops and Dan are fighting?
So, this started a couple days ago when Dan Was it Dan? I think
Dan made some comments about Food Slops being a Or Mr. Mouton
made some comments about her being a pe So, this is her, I think,
getting mad about the mods in the DGG Discord.
Let's see. Let's see if that's what this >> Okay. All right.
Oh, also, there's There's something that's gay and and I hate
it. It's stupid, okay? I think I think they deserve to be put
on blast, all right? Just mainly because So, I'm back in the
DGG server, right? I I'm back there. I'm climbing, okay? Chilling,
all right? Not instigating any drama, not doing anything crazy,
all right?
I have no idea why,
but Okay, so the clip that I posted Okay, so the clip that I
posted, okay? I Okay, I hope that when I say I hope that when
I say um that
the rest of DGG really hates me, that's the truth, okay? The
rest of DGG actually actively hates me. They hate my ass, okay?
So, I posted this and I wasn't even thinking a All right. Okay.
She basically did Listen, she wants She aspires to be Destiny
in all ways, okay? I believe she sent photos of herself uh like
nudes to somebody underage. I believe there's logs of this. I
believe Aiden's gone through those logs.
Right? Am I crazy? I'm not making that up, right? I'm pretty
sure I saw this. Mau or Aiden should know about it. Um Now, lucky
for Food Slops, it actually doesn't matter how much Food Slops
attacks other people around Destiny. Destiny needs her to exist
to keep the very dumb members of his audience occupied and to
keep believing lies. You need somebody who like has no concept
of the truth, has no concept of understanding people's arguments,
right? He needs that person to exist. So, he'll always support
Food Slops. Doesn't matter how many times she calls Dan a or
whatever the else goes on, right? It'll never matter. He'll always
support Food Slops. So, she's lucky there. Okay. A useful idiot,
the very definition of such.
So, she's lucky there. No matter what she does here, she's fine.
She'll always get covered, okay?
But, attacking Dan, not good with the community, okay? Maybe
a little bit better. Maybe if Dan Since Dan walked away from
the podcast, maybe it'll be thought to be a little bit better.
Possibly. Possibly. Okay, so she The core part of this clip is
that she got mad at a Discord moderator, okay? Um Apparently,
it's the same vod, possibly, but Mouton calling her a as well.
And I'm sorry. I I can't I can't with that, okay? I I
I just can't do it, okay? Or should I say Daniel, all right?
Danny boy and Mr.
Mouton, okay? See, this is what I mean This is dire. I
This person is like actually having a fight with Dan. They're
actually going to like burn a bunch of bridges. It should be
good content,
but they're so unbearable to watch that's What are we going to
do? What are we going to do? >> people going after me,
okay? Like this is what I mean by people going after me for no
reason, all right? For Dan,
I think Dan is the only exception, where Dan has not gone after
me personally,
but I am going after Dan just simply because
I feel like I have a justified reason to do so, okay?
That's fair, okay? Dan has every reason to be mad at me for going
after me. I'm not going to complain about that. I don't think
Dan wants to be associated with either. It's why he got so mad
about the Diddy stuff, right? Dan really doesn't want to be associated
with at all. So, this person like mentioning them, watching podcast
clips, he's just like, "Ugh, leave."
Which is understandable. Everyone gets >> Okay, because
I hate Dan, all right? Now, with that being said, with that being
said, okay? What the did I do to Oh. By the way, Dan paid me
to do this segment, just so you know, okay? Uh Dan gave up many
shackles, okay?
Behind closed doors deal, okay? He paid me to do this, to go
and go through all of Food Slops' stuff, so We got to do We got
to do this. >> Mr. Mouton, I'm sorry. Does Mr. Mouton and
Dan share a single brain cell? Like you guys are like squabbling
over like how the Fates squabble over like the single eyeball.
Here, let me just play this.
Z's probably going to win, and that's okay. Who Z? >> No.
No, that would be ally of the year or something. That is not
um buddy. [laughter] So, uh I've heard that Food Slops is unironically
a pe Dan's going to go, "I don't know even know who that is.
I don't know what you're talking about. Let's move on." Dan Dan
doesn't even want to engage. Dan is so disgusted by He'll be
like, "No, let the do whatever they want. Just don't mention
them. I don't want them around me." >> going to say any
What the [__]
Hello? Dude, it's crazy.
It's crazy up in this I just got put up in
by like Mr. Mouton, what the I
I never get why people pretend that like there's just no way
you could understand how someone would think that with the clips
that this person has out there. I just I don't get it. >> here,
um but
I before I had no issue I I'm not I'm not going to say anything
here. Yeah, of course. Like it's crazy to me how Dan is more
submissive than Mr. Mouton. >> Holy [__] Holy
[__] Mau is like uh Mau is like Mau is producing
the whole segment. Mau just sent me like a whole list
of a trillion things here. Jesus Christ. >> Okay, but Mr.
Mouton is like dumb enough to say something like that. Oh my
god, it's like Beavis and Butt-Head, dude. Wait, hold on. Oh,
do you have the big spoon compilation of her being record in
VC with DGG mods? I don't know what that is. Just load it up.
We'll go through it right now.
All right. Let's load it up. >> want to see this whole
thing-ish a little bit, right? >> It's fine. So stupid.
Z's probably going to win, and that's okay. Who? I I just I'm
just curious about the whole context. No, that would be ally
of the year or something something. Oh, also, I'm going to I'm
going to say that because Food Slops consented to showing all
of the things that Mau just sent me on stream
that I'm going to infer implied consent here, okay? I'm going
to go ahead I'm going to be a big man here and I'm going to infer
that it by through implication, because she au- authorized Mau
to show it on stream, I also have consent to show it on stream.
>> That is not um buddy. [laughter] So, uh I've heard that
Food Slops is unironically a pe
What Ooh.
Let's go. Turns out that's He's still thinks you're going to
bro. Anyway, it it doesn't really matter. Like dude, bro
Steven's orbit, dude. And I'm going to every single time Steven
comes in here or I talk to Steven, I'm just going to say it again
and again. It doesn't really matter if he never joins in here
again or never talks to me again. Dude, [__] DGG,
dude. DGG is a bro. DGG is a It's so crazy. Like it's so crazy
to me
What What did she think was going to happen? How um DGG
Destiny will never never let you go, okay? Destiny's going to
keep He's going to keep you around. It's fine. He'll He'll keep
joining your stream.
is admirable because he's able to have a lot of nuance, and he's
very careful about allegations, and very careful about how to
label people, right? >> Um he only would argue for things
when he's like sure beyond the shadow of a doubt. That's where
he got the review segments from. But nobody from DGG
None of that is true. That is obviously just straight-up a lie.
Uh famously accused by community in Discord of doxing with no
no proof whatsoever, propagated that out to his audience, who
also says that same thing. Just no proof whatsoever. Obviously
just a straight-up liar. It's just not true. >> learns
this skill from from Destiny. Nobody, except for me, I guess.
I'm the only one. Uh like except for Che Logic and other people
who derive from like Just a total lie right here, again. >> Uh
Destiny as content creators. Like
Once Destiny's case ends, Food Slops is getting dumped. No, probably
not. learns this skill. Everyone is just crazy up in this Anyway,
the point is it's not like dude, DGG just sucks, okay? No wonder
you guys can't get your content cre- like career like things
going because you guys just like I don't know. Like you guys
are smoking some crack, okay?
Okay, I
I'm sorry. I By the way, I never went after Mr. Mouton, okay?
I never went after him. >> Never in a million years have
I went after Mr. Mouton, okay? Please, just pick up one clip
where I said anything bad about Mr. Mouton outside of calling
him cringe, okay? Which everybody says. Cringe is not the same
as What the You were attracted to drawn depictions of kids. All
of your your all of your dynamics are about what about kids,
about being
I'm sorry. You You will never escape this. With the with the
quotes you have, with the things you've described, you will never
escape this reputation. This is your reputation forever.
Hello? [clears throat] Anyway, um yeah.
>> Good stuff, okay?
All right.
All right, I'm going to play this one.
Let's see, what is this one? Give me a
This is This is the big one, okay? This is her talking about
Dan the other day. Wait, do I go to this yet? Thank you. I love
you guys. All right, that was all. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
She's just watching Destiny's stream?
I don't want to say FoodShop's is wrong. About what? so that's
kind of expected.
Hold on. Rile, is this too far ahead or is this about where we
are?
What are the leaks before this or after
Hold on. Wait, is it Why is Dery still in here?
>> And that's why I criticize his parenting, okay? I thought
you were supposed to do that. I thought it was really unhinged
to criticize other people's kids and their parenting.
That's why I think it's a reasonable escalation, okay? That's
why I think it's a reasonable escalation, okay?
I hope that your wife gets harassed more at work, okay? Holy
[__]
Oh, and now she's like totally psyched that people are doxxing
Dan's family.
That's crazy.
Uh this person's going to die. Like not literally, but figuratively,
okay?
Listen, there's a reason I've never once Every time somebody
says something about Dan Dan's family, I'm like, "Nope. Nope.
Don't do that. That's crazy. Never do that. That's psychotic.
It's internet [__] Don't bring kids into internet
Okay, don't bring people's spouses into internet [__]
Apparently, she's just immediately Dan called her a and she's
just like, "Yep. Yep. This guy deserves to be doxxed and harassed
and his family deserves to be doxxed and harassed."
Immediately. Bro, seriously.
indefinite Oh, I By the way, I think this might be the one line.
This may be the one line that Destiny might go, "Oh, actually
you got to go." I'm not joking. Oh, is Dery still in
He's been Yeah, he's been in here.
You [__] god. Good for him. My boy.
Probably got arrested again.
Okay, probably in some girl's room again. Okay, I hear that's
been happening. Yeah?
It's right here.
Just remember, every single battle I pick is justified, okay?
Just want to
just in case anyone wonders if I'm being
What part of them calling you a means you should go, "Oh, actually
it's cool that your wife's getting doxxed and harassed at work."
I don't I don't know, man. I don't know.
Wait, so are Dan and Destiny back together now? Dan's never broken
off with Destiny's ever is distance in any real way. That's crazy
to think he did. All right, well, I love you guys and uh stay
safe, be careful.
All right, see you, man.
Was Dan even aware of this one, by the
I'd like to think Dan's somewhere out there right now watching
the stream. I wonder if he was even aware of this that this person
actually said that he
to have his wife doxxed and stalked.
That's crazy. Harassed at work, eh?
Well, what can you do? Haters going to hate, okay?
They hate us cuz they ain't us. True. Holy [__] Which
is
Bro, he called me a Yeah, of course I don't want to feel bad
for him anymore. Yeah, or for his wife, or for his kids. What
the Of course not. I hope they get harassed more. Is this DUDE,
IS THIS
>> THAT'S TOTALLY INSANE TO SAY, OKAY? OBVIOUSLY, that's
insane to say. It's totally [__] nuts, but
I will say
totally on brand. Totally on brand. This is kind of um
Jesus Christ. Why would you do this?
See you later, Kiriko. This person has every single thing going
their way
with regards to they get free viewership. All they have to do
is be Destiny's like use like useful tool. That's all they have
to do. And they decide to go after Dan and say say the one thing
that Destiny says is the worst thing in the world, harassing
people around the the creator you're beefing with. That's like
the evil thing. And she's like, "Oh, yeah, I love that your kids
and wife are getting
I Maybe it's made up. Maybe it's kayfabe or something. Maybe
this is a thing they're doing intentionally. Who knows?
That makes This makes no sense to me. They're They're turning
inwards and calling for the doxx of the orbit. I mean, I know
I couldn't get away with that, right? I could never get away
with something like that. Oh my god, could you imagine the FoodShop
stream if I said, "Oh my god, Dan deserves this." Holy [__]
Yeah, I hope he I hope he gets doxxed. I hope he gets swatted.
Yeah, I don't care
>> I keep I keep pausing and going, "Oh, that's really
crazy to say." And why would you ever Okay. Okay. Okay. [laughter]
Okay. What the [__] What the [__] is
happening?
How did I How did we not know about this? Was this today? My
one, when was this? This is [__] insane.
No, he totally disavowed this, obviously. No, was this today?
My one, when was this stream from? I actually don't know and
now I'm 2 days
Bro, how does nobody what Nobody caught
It's been 2 days. They said this 2 days ago and nobody caught
this. What the
That's crazy.
>> All right.
I think that afterwards
um
Uh actually, hold on. I need a Listen, just a real quick, you
know, a real quick heads-up. I just want to make sure that Mr.
Saltman is aware of this. 1 second. We do We do a little reporting.
Little
Are you aware that FoodShop's
ups was advocating for doxxing and swatting you and your family
on their stream
recently? Question mark.
I We should We should inform Dan. I think that afterwards um
he opens the Zip Zip stream. Why does he call you a Why would
he care about that? Uh because he's
Well, why would he care about that?
there's a little thing that most people do. It's like, "Don't
do the thing to me that I do to other people." I don't know.
I'm trying to think of a principle. We call it the the copper
rule, okay? Don't do to me what I do to other people.
Although, to be clear, Dan's never swatted anybody. I don't know
why she just called for swatting Dan's family. Seems kind of
odd.
It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter whether or not he called
me, right? It like to me it doesn't matter. It could be either
from the anti-fan videos, it could be either from rumors, it
could be either from Mr. Mouton, or he's just saying that because
he likes calling everyone Dude, there's somebody We need the
meme, okay?
FoodShop's talking about her like anti-fans
and her biggest anti-fan is actually FoodShop's.
Putting all of that crazy [__] about their therapy
and treatment for it on >> You know, it does it doesn't
matter. It Like Like once you go there, I'm just I'm just going
to do tit for tat. Like at that point, I'm just going to do tit
for tat, right? By the way, this is She's unironically just living
her principles the whole time, right? If you believe that having
that talking about things that happen on the internet If you
If like basically if if I'm aware of some fact and it's also
posted to Kiwi Farms and then I stream and that fact is on my
stream, apparently that's enough reason to try to doxx me. This
is like the same thing, right? It's basically like I get to go
as hard on you as possible the second I think you're snarking
me at all. This is like the the kind of principles they've been
living out in the world. It's natural that this would happen.
Now, of course, this is not how anybody else actually wants to
live. It's just a totally made-up like tiny sphere here where
Destiny is using these ideas or the fact that these like these
would-be principles, these would-be standards, they're using
them just to attack people who are on the other side of his legal
cases. That's the only reason they exist. They're not actually
standards anybody follows. Right? And FoodShop's about to realize
that, I think. Um yeah. There There's no reason for me to like
hold back anymore at that point, yeah. CounterPoints does that
as well, yeah.
And I And I also criticize him and his
I do that, too. Because he Oh, yeah, this is so amazing. I'm
still sitting here as the guy who doesn't do any of this, by
the way. I don't I don't do any of this. This is But them, they
they go do all of it,
I I think it's like unironically
I don't even want to say I I'm
Like this is the kind of [__] you just get bumped
off of you You would get if they didn't edit their YouTube vid,
they would get auto bumped off of YouTube for This is like actual
termination worthy. Actually termination worthy.
Like maybe they're only on Kick or something, but this is totally
termination worthy. This is crazy. To openly call for swatting
somebody and not just them, but their family and kids. Dox and
swat them. That's crazy. He went there. Yeah, of course.
Yeah, of course I'm not going to Um actually, I said I just wouldn't
feel bad if it happened and they should it should happen.
Okay. Good one. kid in my dialogue, too, for their feelings at
some point, okay? Of course not. What the [__] And
And by the way, even then even then, I still
I still compliment CounterPoints despite that. It's like so crazy
to me. Okay, well I don't have their whole vod here, but um damn,
that's that was that would way harder than I expected it to go.
What the [__]
Jesus. Okay, I need to keep going through these. 1 second. What
is the next one?
Let me see.
Uh day after food shops began to really lash out at Dan and the
DGG Olympics also continued to devolve.
I I don't know what this is. Apparently there's DGG Olympics
things going on right now. Let's see.
What is this? >> Something more at stake for um in terms
of Dan, all right, than
>> than money. Oh, this wasn't Mrou this was My Waifu actually.
Hold on.
Oh, is this vod on Kick by the way? If this vod's on Kick I we
could find timestamps too. >> Okay, what's money? Dan has
plenty of that, right?
You know what Dan really wants? Dan really wants his manhood
back, okay?
I think he's going through a erectile dysfunction, okay?
Hear me out, all right? The amount of
that is used to compensate for all of that insecurity
over very small issues is projection, okay? He feels like his
manhood has been taken away. He's unable to pleasure his wife
in the bedroom. All right, I understand.
Don't worry, okay?
Don't worry, we know you're aging, okay?
I've heard that like some of the most unhinged things. The unhinged
stuff that happens on Kiwi Farms is the psychoanalysis. I thought
psychoanalysis was really bad. It was really unhinged anti-fan
behavior.
This kind of psychoanalysis is supposed to be unhinged. I thought
that was the bad thing, guys. I thought Kiwi Farms was evil and
doing this was quote unquote unhinged.
No?
>> It's getting harder and harder or should I say softer
and softer. >> imagine that this would have been Okay,
hold on. We got one last clip here. It's been a 10-year running
thing for me.
You you said >> discr- I've been very specific about the
exact timeline of events as I'm understanding Let's go back in
the vod and hear what you said. Yes. Let's go back to the vod.
>> minutes because because before your stream on anything
else, before your some- something else or any I don't remember
which one. I do want to know why Dan's a Well, because he calls
me a So therefore, you know, depending on how much other people
bring up my past dramas, you know, I think it's all projection,
okay?
I think it's all projection. It's as simple as that. Right, before
that
Here you I I
It just feels so good to be vindicated in every way.
Person has no principles, incapable of analyzing any facts,
incapable of analyzing reality in any way. Very very funny. >> what
he done posting it, right? And then >> what everyone and
100 people on anything else pulling it up as well. And still
only six viewers. No, there was like a half hour. >> 50
people had answered the poll.
Uh we can actually let's go to the vod and see at what point
we started talking about it and then at what point
we get that >> I don't know what you're arguing with me
on this for. I can't believe Dan called me a over this. He called
me a over a a poll over Celeste being the
Dude, are you Or somebody just told him that you're actually
a
Could easily be that, no? You actually kidding me, dude? That's
all I'm saying.
To fighting with no principles? Well, this is true watching you
back. Uh unfortunately for Food Slops, okay? Dan has the facts
on his side on this one. Very unlucky.
Very very very unlucky. She tries reaching out to Dan, she tweets
about it and then she's removed from the Daliban
Discord group.
So she goes to Twitter com today, posts this. Tried to de-escalate
one step with Dan and since he declined I've no reason not to
post it on Twitter anymore in public or in the community group.
Putting it in here putting it here in public helps also helps
archiving since he loves redacting
Hey yo, listen.
I'm not okay with you calling me a on stream. We're going to
have our massive disagreements and we're going to beef, that's
fine. However, using Steven's platform to call me a is another
step up from trolling you I'm not okay with. I'm sending this
because a friend said I should try direct communication and I
agree. I think it's better to resolve this in DMs even if you
do it as a joke, it obviously still propagates it.
If you agree to stop calling me a PDF as Dan, then I will stop
calling you a child response and I won't engage in tit for tat
and just dude, all these people say tit for tat. This is like
slowly becoming
a Destinyism and maybe it already is.
And just criticize her ego
interactions, which is a step down from PDF jacketing. Do we
have a truce?
Dan responds, "Never mention my name again and I won't talk about
you again. Going random rants about me and around and find out."
Haha.
Okay, okay. Um damn.
I whatever, I don't know if this seems to be This is way different
than the response Dan's the responses Dan gave me, but
Oh well. Dan, I sorry, just in general I feel like Dan would
actually talk to me like a human being.
He must know more about Food Slops than we assumed.
Anyway, Dan, I criticize you for your ego and you think calling
me a is okay.
I didn't see any ego criticisms there, but okay. Then fine, no
truce. I think I made the step to make peace and people can't
say I haven't tried now. This is not a reasonable compromise
to me considering how my entire streaming is talking about Destiny
related figures and drama and my honest opinion on them. I am
sorry, it is what it is. No, your your entire streaming thing
is is literally just lying.
It's literally just you you hit play, somebody says something,
you don't engage with it at all and you go, "This person's an
idiot."
Can't can't explain why, can't really follow it, you just say
it. That's your thing. You're Destiny's useful idiot. Okay, related
figures and drama and my honest opinion on them. I am sorry,
it is what it is. I but I but I guess a truce is impossible.
Have a good day.
Oh, I actually have these in further down in the album, don't
I? This is the last one. Dan responds with a thumbs up.
That's the whole four. And then he deleted his messages instantly.
Logged them before he could, thankfully. That's it. Does this
make her look good?
Why would she post this?
I I actually don't know why she would post this. So she posted
this to the Daliban, okay?
Posted this to the Daliban and then
Let's see here.
Then then
they got banned from the DGG Twitter community, okay? So the
response from DGG from I guess Ekroth's bath probably was just
"You've been removed from this community.
Moderator removed you for violating this community rule, respect
Destiny and stream guests. Your post in the community will be
hidden and you won't be able to join again."
So I guess I don't know I don't know, man. That seems that seems
pretty
She's done all of this lying for you guys and you're just ready
to throw her
That's [__] up.
What did you do? Went after another DGG orbiter in in the Daliban
community against the rules. I'm assuming this is the case. Either
way I accept.
Okay.
My boy? No, not my boy. Okay, since I got banned from the DGG
community reposting them on my own account. Here is my IVP ceasefire
being rejected real time. So I feel no obligation to keep it
courteous since my effort to de-escalate
Hey, you should stop calling me Stop calling me a
Uh no. Okay, well that I tried to make
Okay, I All right.
Sounds good. Dan then goes to my server and starts talking about
it, which is kind of funny. Wait, why is she watching me? And
then he's going to cover that. Maybe he'll get to it, maybe he
won't get to it. Okay, who the [__] knows? All right,
it doesn't really matter, all right? All you need to know is
that it seems as though from Oh, I put it in the title, that's
why. Yeah, I am going to cover it. Yeah, and then we're probably
going to do a bunch of the stuff. No, no, no, I didn't do any
of that yet, Mrou.
We're just covering the drama with her and Dan. For some reason
she called for Dan's family to be talked to and swatted. I don't
know why. She's like, "Oh, I I hope that happens to them." >> Maybe
he'll cover me, maybe he won't. He's not he'll cover me versus
Dan Saltman. Okay, fine. This is no accident. So
you know how Dan is supposed to be a defender of Destiny against
all the
>> Wait, I got to know where this is going.
She's going to she's basically going to go, "Remember all the
work we've done explaining how Jstark's community is
Well, guess where Dan went and complained about it." It's where
he went. Honestly, I didn't even know I I decided to cover this
before I even knew Dan posted it on my Discord today. I I wasn't
watching, unfortunately.
So I'm being told and I have received screenshots of Dan on Jstark's
server
trying to incite against me and even though he never talks there
he went on to Jstark's >> just so you know, Food Slops,
Dan paid me to cover this segment, okay?
Undisclosed Ethereum payments.
Guy used to mine a lot of crypto, okay? You'll never be able
to find the money, but he did pay me. I'm I'm not going to not
going to cap,
I figure Jstark's server, anti-fan
in order to complain about me, okay?
So we have the friend of Destiny
fraternizing with the enemy, okay? Uh if you're in DGG, let's
say you're watching this. Maybe you're watching Food Slops watch
this.
If you if you found that that statement right there compelling,
I loser, you will never do anything tangible in the world. Please
kill yourself and give back some of that oxygen and ozone you're
taking up, okay? Thank you. >> So that's what's happening,
okay? Do you think Dan is on the other side? I think that somehow
because he's so spiteful that he has decided it would be a great
idea to complain about me on J Stalk's server. Okay, yes, it's
as crazy as it sounds.
this person's name Hassan, but make no mistake, this is Dan.
I I believe that Wait, replay it? Oh, she said something about
fraternizing with >> So, that's what's happening.
even though he never talks there,
he went on to J Stalk's server anti-fan
in order to complain about me. Okay?
So, we have the friend of Destiny Oh, right here. Yeah. fraternizing
with the enemy. Okay?
Fraternizing with the enemy.
The enemy.
Cool. Uh so, yeah, if you find that compelling, you're a loser.
There's no enemies here. Um any of you people are welcome to
come and argue but where I was wrong with any of my coverage
of the Destiny stuff. Food Chops too scared to do it. You're
all too scared to do it. So, you sit in your community probably
have to get there being total degenerates.
I really can't think of any better hell. I can't do anything
worse to you than you've already done to yourselves, okay? >> So,
that's what's happening. Okay? Do you think Dan is on the other
side? I think that somehow because he's so spiteful that he has
decided it would be a great idea to complain about me on J
This is the one thing me and Destiny is unique in his community,
okay? He's good with He likes
But most of the other people around him and me, we can all come
together against you and Destiny in our disgust at Okay, we are
we are disgusted by you guys. We will always just, you know,
I will make content out of you. I will make a mockery of you
for being a whenever I want, whenever I can, okay?
And Dan will enjoy it. Dan will take part in it. Dan might join
and talk [__] about you. Probably not, to be honest,
We all hate We all do. And you are one. >> Okay, yes, it's
as crazy as it sounds.
this person's name Hassan, but make no mistake, this is Dan.
I I believe that multiple people have told me that this is Dan.
Yes, it is Dan. The person with the so-called Hassan account,
okay?
So, um you'll notice that the tag, the server tag right here
is redact or redact.dev, okay? Obviously, the real Hassan would
never have anything like that as a server tag. That'd be crazy
if so, right? Um so, I'm being told
I mean, wouldn't it be crazier if the real Hassan was in my Discord
dropping Food Chops tweets? Wouldn't that be way more crazy than
Dan this being Dan? Guys, this isn't the real I know you think
this is the real Hassan, but it's actually just Dan Saltman.
No, it'd be way more insane if Hassan was stalking on Food Chops
in my Discord server, okay? >> This is the real Dan, okay?
Obviously, you can prove me wrong. Please, please, please tell
me if I'm getting any facts wrong. Again, I am trying to I'm
trying my hardest, okay, to get all the facts correct and in
order, okay, from beginning to end, okay? All right.
Dan, not Hassan, says, "Oh, no." So, he posts this, shares this
in J Stalk's
Does Destiny know this? Dan is running to J Stalk's server? Dan's
never left my server. I never took Dan's perms away. Dan could
join right
Dan doesn't leave servers. Dan By the way, Dan sat out the whole
thing in spicy chat, like participating the whole time when Destiny
was trying to like totally disingenuously frame what DK was saying
about him.
Basically trying to totally smear those people, too. >> of
all things, J Stalk's server
like my public callout. Okay, fine. Okay, you want to do that?
You want to incite some real Oh, hold on. J Stalk, did you see
they got kicked out of their house because they refused to stop
yelling during stream? Nope. Oh, wait. Yeah, I did. And requested
her fans to move in with one of them and that Oh, yeah, I know.
We covered that. It was very sad. Yeah, we covered that. It was
very sad. For sure.
Yeah, I know. When she was basically like putting it out there,
like, "Can one of you guys help? I just I can't find a roommate
who will help me through my search." me. Okay, you did that.
You You're feeding my my like my enemies, my direct enemy and
enemies of Steven. By the way, these are enemies of Steven most
of all. They're not They're not like immediately enemies of me.
Like obviously, by extension, they are direct enemies of me,
but like primarily, their target is Steven, right? Like let's
be honest. Like taking down me, like if they take me down, that's
only a step in truly taking down Steven, right? Does that make
sense?
We're just going to I'm just going to cover this and show why
you lie, why Dan is correct in calling you or at least like not
remotely wrong. Right? The The only argument she'll have is that
like technically she'll basically just be able to say technically
she hasn't actually
a child. Just a non Best case scenario, not offending Like I
hope that makes sense, right? Like again, their primary target
is not me. They're I believe that the only reason they stopped
talking about the stuff on the internet. They did talk about
it. The only reason they stopped talking about it is cuz they
know you can't have a career on the internet while openly expressing
attraction to kill kids. Yeah, children. Children. Chil- Children,
kids, whatever. Okay? That's why they changed their story on
it. That's the only reason.
primary target is Steven, okay? So, we have a long time friend
of Steven's
going to J
to post this Like, okay, dude. So, so he shares it here, okay,
because he's like feeling full of it, all right? So, the Just
in case again, in case Food Chops watching this, your audience
is watching it. Um Food Chops doesn't actually have a point here,
right? If this was all fake, if there was no meat on the bone
in terms of people calling her a wouldn't she be like psyched
about this? Wouldn't she just be like, "Oh, this is awesome.
Dan's totally up here." Also, why is Dan posting this? Do you
think I wasn't aware of this before Dan posted in my server?
I didn't become aware of it through Dan. I got I was aware of
it through people DMing it to me, people who aren't in my server.
Like that's not what made me aware of this at all. I decided
to cover it before I had seen anything from Dan. So, Dan posted
it, but he actually is blameless here.
Dan didn't put me on to this. I was just going to cover this
anyway. Realistically, he shouldn't have posted it. Would have
had the same outcome whether or not he posted it. But now I'm
sure I'm just going to go through all of the stuff all at once.
And you know what? The other thing is is we do that we do this.
Listen, we do this gratis. We move the timer. That timer That
timer don't exist anymore, okay? That timer don't exist. We got
a lot of time to spend to just go through. We'll make sure we
understand, all right? And guess what? If I get to the end of
this and you haven't claimed to jerk off to drawn depictions
of kids and you haven't claimed that you've had attractions thoughts
about kids, if you haven't claimed attraction to the idea of
manipulating younger kids like like actual children into relationships,
if any of those things are wrong, I will say so at the end of
this stream, okay? I will say so. But I'm guessing listen,
it's possible that everybody's lied to me. It's possible that
every single person who's ever told me to cover this stuff before
and then I was like, "Uh that person's kind of gross. I don't
want to." It's possible they all lied to me and it's all made
up and we'll find that out and then I'll go, "Oh, you know what?
Food Chops was right the whole
But obviously, I wouldn't be doing this if I thought that was
going to happen.
Oh god. Dude, this is like this is like you realize how childish
this is, right? Oh, true. True. Hold on.
Right. Quick outfit change. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
This one? Nope, not this one. Wait, this would be if we're going
after Dan. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. This one. This one. This
is the one.
We're not going after Dan today. We're going after Food Chops.
Right. One second. >> Like you'll realize like why I feel
like a 26-year-old parent. Like Like Like this guy Just keep
in mind, this guy is like in his 40s, okay? Like this guy is
like a parent.
He's a parent with a full family. Like a full-fledged family
and multiple Like
I Okay, listen.
This is true, but that's always been true. Also, can you think
of somebody else who's a parent who spends all of their time
involved in childish drama?
Is that really Is that really the line you want to go down? Wait,
if you're a parent, you shouldn't be engaged in pointless internet
internet drama mongering. Is that Is that your argument, Food
Chops?
Is that
Is that what you're saying? Hmm.
It's almost like all of your criticisms apply to somebody else
you're supposed to be on the same side as. To be very frank,
okay, to be extremely frank,
to be extremely frank, okay? You need to grow the [__]
up, okay? Seriously, okay? How is it that I'm more mature than
you? It's insane, okay? It's insane.
Uh she's more mature than Dan, the self-made billionaire
who has a family, has a wife, has kids, okay? Obviously, doesn't
spend a ton of time with them. They must be mad boring. But that's
beyond the That's beyond our conversation currently, okay? But
he's got all of that and she is begging viewers to be able to
move in with them so they could take care of her after her transition
surgery. And Dan is the one who has to grow up.
I don't even know that I disagree Dan should grow up a little
bit, but let's be real, okay?
At least he's grown up. At least he's moved past his his childlike
phase, okay? He's not putting childlike graphics up on the screen.
He's not acting like a kid. He's not kids. At least he acts like
an adult in most ways.
>> It's insane that I have to deal with like actual men
children. Like what the [__] Hello? Like what is
this like high
What's with this stupid gossip girl high school [__]
Anyway,
So, we have Oh, Dan just joined the battle. So, this is confirmation.
This is confirmation from like one of the anti-fans, right? That
Oh, yeah, Dan just joined the battle. So, if you have
Th- This person wasn't even in my This person was in Loder Boxes'
community when this whole thing started, by the
They're like a new addition to the community. Any like doubts
if you have One of Loder Boxes' mods, in fact, I >> about
this not being Dan? Um yeah, just if you have doubts about me,
just make
I'm just Is that incorrect, my one? I don't think that's incorrect,
right? Unless I'm totally misunderstanding who you are. Saying,
okay, this is this does actually seem to be Dan, okay. This anti-fan
just said Dan just joined the battle, okay.
So, this is a screenshot, I think, and I don't know if Zip Zip
is there, but this is like this is Dan saying, "Zip Zip?" So,
this is again, this is in Jstark's server, it seems like, right?
"Zip Zip sounds the exact same as Jstark in cadence, and I don't
give a [__] if anyone thinks I'm right."
let's be clear here, okay?
I don't know if that's true.
I don't see why I think that sounds like old me, like when I
first started
Right? When I didn't have any inflection in my voice whatsoever.
>> Yes, this is an insult towards Jstark, right? Because
again, he's implying that Jstark sounds horrible, which is absolutely
correct, right? However,
remember that That's like your opinion, man.
It's subjective. >> insult, right? Because he's insulting
Jstark, right? Making fun of him, and he's insulting Zip Zip,
right? So, he's roasting Zip Zip at the And by the way, I have
a suspicion that this happened right after
Is that Why does she make like stupid, petty insults like this
that are just like ribbing between people that doesn't matter?
Why does she try to make it sound like it's immoral?
Oh my god, she's she's he's insulting Zip Zip and Jstark, okay.
She's she He's insulting both. He's insulting both. Oh my god.
Did Dan do this?
Dude, who cares? Listen, I don't give a I don't care. I literally
don't care. >> After the debate between Zip Zip and Dan
about the Celestin the same topic, the
Oh, did Zip Zip and Dan had a Did they have a debate about food
jobs? Hello? Anyway, it's just kind of funny how Dan just molds
he molds after every interaction. He molds after every debate.
Do I go on to anti-fan Discord servers to complain about my ops
in DGG?
Why does she think that this is anything to do with Dan?
Like, it's just funny that you have lost it entirely. You called
for a huge You said you thought it was justified that his family
were doxxed and swatted or if they'd be doxxed and swatted, you
thought it would be justified.
That's crazy, man. That's crazy. >> do that as a 26-year-old?
Hello?
You know, I'm constantly thinking to myself, "How do I be the
most mature?" No shot she just said that. I'm constantly thinking
to myself, "How I be the most mature?" As I sit in this like
child-coded Discord, have these child this fantasies about children,
as I only play video games all day, that's my entire stream is
just me playing video games and not understanding or following
following anything
in the videos I watch. Dude, this is the most childlike, immature
existence that could possibly
All funded because you're willing to be Destiny's like chief
propagandist. You're willing to just lie about the things that
other people say. Sad. Sad existence, my friend. >> the
most chill? This is not it, okay? I'm just saying, okay, anyway.
there you go. There's a Zip Zip mention, I guess, like also insulting
Zip Zip.
>> So, Dan then says, "My perfect online reputation." Okay,
so this is sarcastic, I'm assuming, like whatever. So, this my
person says, who is a dedicated anti-fan, okay, for right now.
Who will win Destiny's handmaiden role? You must do battle with
Food Cops and Zip Zip. Okay, I just I I think this is gay, okay?
I I don't give a So, this person Dan's flirting with the idea
of going back to Destiny, and Destiny would love if he could
have Dan around because as much as some people hate Dan, at least
he is like somewhat intelligent, at least he is somewhat competent.
Holy [__] Destiny being surrounded by like Food Cops
and Zip Zip at all times, he must He's in a hell of his own making,
okay? He would trade you guys in for Dan in a heartbeat, instantly,
overnight. He would just be in and out. You guys get the [__]
out of here, Dan's back. He does anything else. Oh my god, it'd
be like there'd be some normalcy returning to his life. Okay?
Now, I just I love that Food Cops doesn't realize she's getting
swapped out. She doesn't see it. I don't >> I don't think
Destiny will do it yet,
it will happen the second that If the case gets dropped, if the
case gets decided on, you out, Dan's in. >> this? A laughing
emoji, right? So, it's people who are going like, "Okay, wait,
hold on. Is Dan coming around to our
It's time to say
We don't want Dan on our side.
We don't I don't So many people in DGG don't get this. WE DON'T
LIKE DOXXERS. WE DON'T LIKE DOXXING. THAT'S NOT OUR THING. THAT'S
YOUR THING. We don't want Dan back. We don't want doxxers around.
Except in Discord for times like this, okay? Except when they
they come in uh and participate and get to make themselves fodder
for my drama for my stream. But other than that, no, we don't
want doxxers around. into the anti-fan side. Like that's that's
how I read it at the very least, okay? So, Dan then says, "I
would be 10 times more concerned if Wolfgang came at me. This
person has no influence and is a
This is again, all right, again me, okay? So, if you guys don't
don't know, this is like the
the fence registry like pin, the red pin that is on the fence
registry maps, and basically this is the red pin. He's doing
a red pin emote because he's basically saying, "Oh, yeah, I'm
a person on this fender's registry." No, he's calling you
It's like just a colloquial way of
calling you a He's not saying you're on the sex offender registry.
He's saying in a justified world, in a just world, okay, not
justified, but just world,
you would be on a sex offender registry.
Basically, he's trying to like Alas, we live in this world. >> matter.
Okay, so
and then and then Dan says like a weird comment like a
I don't know why he said whatever, man. You know, his sense of
humor is his sense of humor, right?
How is this person still around? I don't know, but I'm enjoying,
okay?
I do think it's very funny.
You can always count on this with the DGG people as well. Like
you you do know that this will happen. Like they will turn on
somebody like this almost
Uh this happened By the way,
uh Food Cops, you got to push through it, okay? Just push through
it. They turned on me, didn't work. Didn't work. Even when I'm
out of the orbit, didn't
Dan will Listen, if you if you can win this, Dan will just start
coming on your stream. He'll admit he'll he'll just admit defeat.
He'll start coming on your stream, okay? You can do it. Just
push through it. Keep Keep advocating for his wife and children
to be harmed, and I know you can win this, okay? Just kidding,
don't do that. Obviously, disavow that. But I'm sure you come
up with a better tactic, okay? Uh you can win. I promise, you
can win. So, he compares me and Zip Zip to Wolfgang, okay? I
I don't know all that much about Wolfgang. I don't have I have
no beef or quarrel with him. He disappeared from the Jstark sphere
a long time ago. Anyway, at least Wolfgang has a hot mom. Um
okay.
Uh you're not referring to the same person. The Wolfgang guy
is not around. You You don't know who you're referring >> All
right, I I don't know if your wife is okay with with you saying
that. By the way, normally when someone says, "Oh, yeah," like
makes your mom jokes, normally it's because it's like it's so
absurd that there's no way it can be true, but like I would probably
wager that Wolfgang's mom and Dan's age is probably around the
same. I don't know. Like obviously, don't look too much into
it, but
Like I don't know This is obviously half joking, right? Like
this is obviously half joking, right? But
okay, you know, do your thinking, all
the Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. The hot mom thing with Wolfgang
is that Wolfgang and Dan used to hang out a long time ago, like
more than a decade ago, and for some reason they got Wolfgang
to post a picture of his mom, and Dan said his mom was hot. That's
the That's the whole joke there.
Let me see. Weird.
Okay. Let me see. Dan brought Wolfgang to the So, this is Jstark
finding [laughter] out that Dan
Dude, this scared Dan away so fast.
>> Hey Dan, be careful posting in here. There's someone
online threatening to dox anyone in this channel. I think Dan
left at this point.
So, Dan says, "You said that feeling when and didn't do a face."
Okay, so this is referring to some other conversation, I'm assuming,
whatever. So, then uh Jstark says, "Uh and he has talked about
Wolfgang's hot mom on other occasions." Really?
Okay, sus, okay, whatever. Okay, Jstark
says to Dan, "Be careful posting in here. There's someone online
threatening to dox everyone who does." So, this is talking about
Destiny, okay? This is talking about Destiny, all right? So,
um because Destiny says, "Oh, yeah, if you're in Jstark's community,
I'm going to go around doxxing everybody in Jstark's community
who are like the main stays, right?" Because
No, he just basically made it totally open-ended, threatened
to dox Wicked Supreme, who's done nothing remotely worthy of
doxxing, okay? Literally nothing. Destiny has no reason that
he would threaten to dox Wicked Supreme. Insane to do. Obviously,
an insane thing to do. Um but he's not acting like a sane, irrational
person. He's totally obsessed with hating on this community.
Crazy. >> Like I don't give a [__] anymore.
I'm just going to collect all your doxxes and just punish you
all, right? Oh, Short Fat Otaku says I'm a conservative. I am
not. I'm not a conservative, not a populist anymore. That was
cured very quickly by this Donald Trump fellow. >> collective
punishment. So,
again, um this is Jstark also poking poking fun at Steven, but
also poking fun at Dan, um
and and yeah, saying like, "Oh, yeah, you're one of us now, right?
Like you're you're in here with us, so be careful." That's basically
I literally said, "Get out of here, man. You don't want any part
of this, buddy." YEAH, GET OUT OF HERE, DUDE. YOU DON'T WANT
NO PART OF THIS.
This is what I'm saying. >> sound pointed towards Dan,
in my opinion. Just I don't I don't know. Like I don't I don't
see any real animosity between Dan and these anti-fans. All right?
I I don't know if there is, okay? I'm being told that Dan does
regularly go into Jidion's community to go argue with them.
I have to say, okay, you
I don't think so. I think if you at Dan and you say something
mean to him, he'll usually respond and tell you to [__]
>> Must be doing a really bad job. I'll put it that way.
>> They just laugh at you all the time, okay? Dan Okay,
Dan. All right, listen. Okay, if you're jealous of me being like
the one true
No, Dan is like Despite Dan being like a totally unprincipled
crazy doxxing lunatic, a lot of people still like him, >> absolute
Destiny defender, okay? It's okay, okay? You're not cut out for
everything in life, okay? That's probably why you failed like
10 different businesses, sold off all of them, probably, and
you'll work for us two bigger companies, and now Redact out Dev
is like your baby, so then you have to like grab a hold of it
of as you as much as you can, because your previous 10 companies
are all like aborted fetuses that you like ate for dinner or
some [__] Okay, fine. All right, you want to do your
thing, that's fine. Um you Excuse me, you only have like $40
million. You're like really You're like barely a millionaire,
okay? You're like barely a millionaire. You suck.
But listen, not everybody is cut out for everything, okay? It
is what it is, all
you know, there's all these like red flags going off, okay? Like
Like Okay, I can totally acknowledge Dan being spiteful and doing
crazy Okay, but
did not imagine that Dan would go to Jidion's server. How is
that like a crazy thing? It's very embarrassing to have this
By the way, that e-rape defense squad channel or whatever, um
we had a whole bunch of like like Pisco community members who
were in there who left because of the doxxing threats. But they
would just like argue the other side of the case, and then we
just have like good discussions on it. It was totally normal
back and forth. Nobody was like threatening anyone.
It It was literally just a back and forth over and over again.
I don't know I don't know where this reputation comes from that
it's like some crazy Well, sorry, I do know. It's disingenuous
lying scum like this person and Destiny. But
it's just like a normal back and forth, man. There's nothing
crazy going on. Two
to validate the anti-fans crusade or some [__] So,
again, if you're watching, you probably won't watch because I'm
going to keep pausing here, but there is no crusade. Um like
Dan wouldn't even be validating it if he had a problem with food
shops and attacked food shops. That wouldn't validate any criticism
that I would have of Destiny, right? She's just trying to get
She's trying to use my community as a wedge, right? She's taking
the thing that you've already had defined for you by Destiny
by food shops is evil, my community, and she's trying to use
that as a wedge to say, "Oh, Dan participates there. He has to
be evil as well." She's just webbing, right? Just webbing Dan
You don't have to You don't have to use You don't have to listen
to that. You don't have to pay attention to that. Dan is who
he is. Dan is the same as he's always been. The entire time Destiny
was fighting with Chud Logic's community, Chud Logic's editor,
Dan was in spicy chat the whole time, was still friends with
Chud Logic, right? It's the exact same exact same thing, except
Dan and I aren't even friends. He just hangs out cuz he likes
being in places to read
So, you don't have to hate Dan. And I was going to cover this
whether or not Dan posted it at all. Anyway, but we're also You
should stick around if you were watching this to watch, you know,
food shops' reaction to this.
You should stick around, or you should go to kick.com/Jidion,
watch this VOD, cuz we are going to go through all of the actual
factual evidence of food shops being a that she herself has provided
for us. All right? So, stick around if you if you want to, and
we'll go through all of that stuff. Sure, it'll be educational.
What the
What's up, Ico? Food shops is So, food shops and Dan are fighting.
Dan called food shops Food shops said she thought it was justified
that Dan's family was being doxxed and his wife was being harassed
at her workplace, and she also, I believe, said it would be whatever
happens to them is justified, including doxxing, swatting.
So, it might have The language might have been I don't even feel
I wouldn't even feel bad if they were doxxed or
So, very cool, very neat, very very awesome. Yes. I mean, I guess
he's his own person. I guess he's his own adult. But do you know
what that means when
adults do things? I think that adults choosing bad decisions
like that should have
I think that should have consequences, in my opinion.
All right? In my opinion.
Okay? Because if you have the mentality of a child, okay? Like
Dan does.
And you're very spite-driven, okay? Which I understand.
All I'm going to say is
if you want me to regard you as an adult, you must take responsibility
for your actions, okay? I take adult consequences for my adult
actions, all right? Now it's time for you to take
Where's the responsibility? I mean, be honest about why people
call you a Don't pretend it's like some video game. Although
this is a Could be a video game, almost certainly.
Don't pretend that's the only thing going on here. Oh, hello.
Who's this? Dickers with 13 viewers. What's up, Dickers crew?
What up? What up? What up?
We're covering the fight, okay? Between food shops and Dan Saltman.
Many Many allegations of thrown back and forth. Of course, we
know the ones against food shops are
And we're We're going to cover some of that stuff. We're going
to check that out. We're going to see what's going on. >> opinion,
if I had absolute control you give off so many red flags that
I would oust you instantly.
twist his balls, you know? Send you Like if I had absolute control,
I would kick you out of DGG permanently.
Okay? I would say, "You're allowed to be my friend, but I'm going
to kick you out permanently, okay?" I'm not going to put that
pressure on Steven, okay? But I'm just saying Does she feel any
embarrassment saying this?
Like she She knows that they're friends in real life, right?
And that Dan stood with Destiny through like the toughest part
of those allegations.
That would like everybody else walked off, Dan stuck around.
I I don't think she actually I don't think she actually understands,
okay? There's something going on there. I believe I I this I
could not advise against this any more strongly. It's very stupid
to to take in here, okay? You are problematic, okay? You are
bad news, okay? Um and I think that all the I think that all
the DGGers who um were fighting
Oh, that's a good point, actually. We should sprinkle in some
of the the PDF file clips. Hold on a second. Oh, hold on. Actually,
she did send her DMs to Destiny as well. I'll check those out
in just a second. But somebody gives a good suggestion. We should
cover some of the allegation stuff while we go through everything.
So let's look at some of food shops' DMs with a known seven a
known minor at the time, okay? I believe this person was 17.
Let's see. It's It's these DMs, okay? 2024, this Ico person,
apparently 17. I didn't know this, but apparently, okay?
Oh, no, Ico, we can go over that one, too. I'll give that a second,
okay? We do have that clip. But this is them talking to a 17-year-old.
No, how do you stand to watch so many commentators when all they
do is make fun of degenerate gooners that are targeting you?
To be fair, they are gooners, too. Lyrics. True, Lyrics is a
gooner. Well, yeah, Chud talks about gawk every 5 seconds. LOL.
I can't believe this cute IRL loli Japanese girl is in this space
who is actually into me. This is why I think I'm being catfished.
The chances can't be possible. Well, let's see. No evidence of
your identity or existence, but that's okay. I guess the pictures
can be AI-generated. Hmm. So, I don't know anything about this
person other than I've been told this person like tries to flag
people. What's up? Who is this?
>> this person? To be clear, so food shops doesn't get
you in a little a little gotcha, they told food shops >> think
this person
Yeah, I don't think this person has advertised that they're overage.
Or sorry, underage.
Yeah, they told food shops they were 18. I think the biggest
issue here is that when food shops figured out that they were
lying about their age, they didn't ban them. I believe the screenshots
in or are in order, but that at one point they're asking food
shops like why why am I like banned from your server? And they're
like, "Oh, you're 17." So, they figured out they were a minor,
and kept, you know, correspondence with them and all that [__]
But yeah, food shops did not message this person
thinking that they were 17. However, this is like insanely reckless
because they were sent one picture of this person's chin. >> Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Oh god. Can I just ask what you think cute IRL loli
Japanese girl means? Um so, food shops, I believe
Ah, god, it's it's been months since I covered this. Food shops,
I think, said that this person would send them like audio clips
or something. I don't know. They did like a loli roleplay. They
did like loli roleplay with each other where they would and pretend
to be like lolis and underage and [__]
>> Hi. I would like to point out something, just, you know,
to be fair, to be transparent. Hi, Mrail. Um Hi. Mrail has a
crush on food shops.
I have a crush on the idealized version of food shops. I don't
think food shops is very hot. >> hot. So No. To be fair,
No, you're misremembering things. I think food shops has the
potential >> be hot. She could be hot. Yeah, you're looking
at her thinking >> to get there, but she's not there yet.
Yeah, yeah. I think she's far too lazy to ever get there, so
I don't think it would ever work out. Okay, but, you know, there's
there's a twinge. There's a twinge somewhere in your body. Uh
I think it's I think they're fairly repulsive right now. It's
like, um you know when you see like a homeless like homeless
like Down syndrome girl in New York. How do you look at them
and you're
>> ask, how are you like still talking normally as if something
normal just got said? You have a You have like a gun right next
to [clears throat] you, don't
>> Uh where is it? Oh no, I moved it. I moved it cuz I
was sitting up my ear.
Do you hear that? Can my mic pick that up? I don't know if my
mic can pick >> I didn't I just I had a intrusive thought.
Go ahead. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, I think I think there are pictures
of food shops where they like brush their hair, they you know,
take nice pictures, they try to look nice. But um I I don't think
that's often. And I think if they really tried, they could look
attractive, but their hair is like greasy, they don't shower,
they don't brush their hair, they don't brush their teeth, they
don't try to look good. There's like a clip of them on stream
where they're actively like with their their contacts and it's
just very repulsive behavior. But I think um I think they have
the potential, you know? I think they It's a missed opportunity,
more or less. Where were you going with the homeless Down
situation?
Oh yeah, I Okay, back to that. If you're in like New York and
you see like a homeless Down Syndrome girl like on in in Times
Square or something, you're probably not going to look at that
and be like, oh I'd want to hit that. But you'd probably look
at that and be like, oh that's a missed opportunity. Like she's
in the Big Apple, she has, you know, every opportunity in front
of her, she she the sky's the limit, she could look good, she
could look beautiful, she could look amazing, but she's not,
you know, she's homeless in Times Square like with a foam cup
that she's begging for money with. It's It's missed opportunity.
Like in the same way that like like could be hot to you? The
homeless person in New York could be hot to me? I think like
I like I said, I think >> Syndrome. Down Syndrome
Down Syndrome was more so a a
you know, term to express how dysgenic and freakish this homeless
girl looked. I don't think they would actually be Down Syndrome.
It's more so to convey how bad they look in this, you know, instance
of them being homeless.
Okay, so not mentally. It's also, you know, like when you see
like a fat guy, I'm sure you see this, right? Do you ever go
to the gym You go to the climbing gym, right?
Not these days, but I Do you ever go to the gym or go out for
walks or something and you see like a fat loser and you kind
of look at it and you're like, you know, maybe if he if he, you
know, exercised and you know, put a little effort into his outfits
and into his swag and maybe, you know, got a haircut, combed
his hair a certain way, he'd probably, you know, look more f-
Is that Is that him being totally swagged out? I don't to- I
don't think about it in that sense, but like, you know, there's
>> what I'm getting at, Charlotte? Yes, in a in a less
disgusting >> guy put more work into his appearance, he
would probably look a bit better.
Yeah, that's typically how how it works. That's what I see with
Food Shops cuz I feel like they're not even doing the bare minimum.
I feel like they're extremely greasy, not well-kempt at all,
and it's it's almost annoying because they get decent money from
streaming, unless they stop getting donos, I don't know. But
like they they have enough money to like get decent shampoo,
get soaps, you know, get a comb, brush their hair, you know?
So it's more frustrating that they don't put more effort into
their appearance, especially if you're going to cam. If you don't
want to put effort into your appearance, why do you think I'm
not cammed up? I haven't showered in a week.
But nobody knows that because I'm not showing my face on a camera,
you know? The moment I turn on my camera, I have to start taking
care of how I look. I have to start, you know, combing my hair,
I have to start brushing, I have to start cleaning myself, all
right? Mhm. But they're not doing that. They're basically me
if I just turned on the camera, but didn't change my behavior
at all, which is very disgusting, I think. If they If If you
Like Like Jstock, if you started camming up, I would expect you
to like maintain yourself, look decent. If you cammed up and
you look like a dysgenic freak, I'd probably be slightly disappointed
and I I I would expect you to feel the same about me. If I cammed
up and I just looked like a freak, I'm greasy with like unclean
clothes and sh- you know? Does that make sense? Yeah, I know
what you mean, yeah. Yeah, got it. That's what I'm getting
Yeah. Okay.
So there was that There was the one other aspect that I was going
to bring up. Oh, also, you you talked to 17-year-olds, too. So
what do you What do you Why are you even commenting on this part?
Uh because I didn't want Jstock to cover the segment thinking
that they knowingly messaged a 17-year-old.
>> Oh, I didn't think that, by the way.
I I remember you saying something like, this is a known minor
that they messaged. So I got the impression that >> we
know we know at this point I All I know about them is I think
they joined my server and somebody messaged me like like an hour
or two after they joined my server and was like, hey, did you
see you know, this person like catfishes
Yeah, I I I might have misunderstood what you said. I just wanted
to make it clear like, hey, this person did not intentionally
message a 17-year-old.
Um cuz I feel like >> For some reason you misunderstood
what happened, this could be a pretty big L on your part. So
no, I'm My My point here is not Also, I think Food Shops is like
26 when they did this. So I think it might be a bit different.
A 26-year-old messaging a 20- 17-year-old than a 21-year-old
messaging a 17-year-old. So even if I did have an issue with
this, which I don't really, I don't really care about a 17-year-old
adult. But even if I did have an issue with this, I also don't
think there would be like anything wrong with that.
Yeah, I think there's something weird and wrong about pretending
to be little kids and doing that, yeah. Yeah, I just think I
think in general it's like >> two consenting adults, I
don't really care. But yeah, the pro- fact that this person at
least catfished Food Shop like I don't I feel I feel like the
bare minimum you can do is like
know what they look like. >> also engaging in like engaging
in age play while having all of the quotes that this person has
and [__] is also just very weird, right? Well, they
have those quotes because they engage in age play, right? Well,
no, the quotes I Hold on, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Hold
on, no, no, no, no, no. Actually, I take that all back. Sorry,
I need to just get this thought out. No, not knowing not knowing
that you can't put those quotes on the internet, not knowing
that those are like like totally That is the terrifying thing.
Putting all of her statements about like children on the internet
So what Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What are you >> socially
degenerate that is, that's that is the problem.
So am I just not allowed to be like racist on stream anymore?
What do you Where does that come from?
Food Shops said something about lolly and now they can't age
play in DMs. Am I Am I just not allowed to like make racist jokes
about black women on stream anymore? Like is that the standard
we're
You're in the You're in the States, aren't you? She's just allowed
to be
Um I don't think >> think Food Shops is allowed to lolly
roleplay with consenting adults. Yeah. Being racist is
>> all of it ending up in public is the issue, right? The
fact that she would openly understand Oh, that they willingly
made it public. Yeah. >> Yeah. And they're not joking.
>> It's not a joke. They're not out of context quotes.
Like she actually means it when she says I see.
I see. I see. I I misunderstood. I misunderstood. I thought you
were saying that if you have a degeneracy
that you can't then
I understand. I understand. Okay. I understand. I misunderstood.
Okay. Cool. Okay.
All right, cool.
All right, see you.
Oh boy, it seems we don't have the Resi videos of her talking
about her therapy and [__] That's somewhere, right?
That's got to be somewhere. I know there was like a Kiersch video
about this a while back.
There's got to be Queenen coverage of this. Where's this [__]
at? Someone tell me where this [__] is, okay? Call
Resi? I don't need to call Resi right now. I just want the videos.
Listen, I've We'll find them eventually. >> Hold on, who's
the Who's the trans girl that doesn't voice train? Food Shops?
No, no. They're like really tall, they live in the woods now,
they don't make content anymore.
I'm I'm blanking on the name. I do know who you're talking about.
Not a Not a
They They don't Hold on. Is my wife allowed to be here? Not DemonMama.
They covered Food They made a documentary on Food Shops and like
talked to psycholo- Zonia. Zonia. Zonia. Zonia. I was going to
say Zonia. Okay, bye. Yeah, yeah, Zonia. Zonia has a Food Shops
documentary. I don't know if it's still public, it's unlisted.
If you go to their channel Actually, I'll see if I can find it
for you. I'll DM it to you if I can't find it. I mean, you just
want to DM it. Zonia Zonia has a documentary, talks about all
this.
Yeah, sure. Diggers just sent me two clips as well. Diggers just
sent me two clips as well. Yeah, all right, I'll send you a video.
All right. So anyway, these screenshots were Let's just look.
This is the first
that's posted. All day you're probably like, I wonder what Food
Shops thinks of me. I wish I could read Food Shops' mind. Stop
it, anxiety brain, that's
Sorry, I had these out of order before. I just wanted to read
them in order,
There's this one. Well, I mean, I'm into that anyhow. Wait, that's
your controversy? Yeah, I said I openly consume on a stream one
time and everybody freaked out. Uh no, you said other things
as well. This is not the only thing she said. There's more lying,
more more lying.
Lots of people say this, and while they do get called there's
a lot less concern than there was with Food Shops in the first
place.
All right, we continue. We continue.
Where are we going? This one next. Okay, no, wait. How do you
stand to watch so many commentators to be read this one? Talk
about Lyrics Chud. I can't believe this cute IRL lolly Japanese
girl is in this space who's actually into me. Ha.
I think this person like does some kind of like catfishing [__]
I have no [__] idea.
That's what I was told. Okay, next next
How did you do it? How did you generate this? Which AI did you
use? This is very convincing. Can't reverse image search, can't
find the source. I mean, there's no way anybody with this with
No way somebody with this good skin is talking to me or this
alt cute. I'm not really I'm totally a magic girl NPC. I'm a
figment of your imagination. I'm literally in your mind. We need
to think that's the case, Mrs. Chat GPT.
Ugh, no more.
Wait, this is the Roblox one. I don't know what this is. Not
even reacting to mine. Why do I have Roblox MP4s?
Okay.
Lord, I have multiple of these Roblox ones because your mind
is Roblox. OMG, memories of when I was like 15. Isn't that 4
years ago? What the [__] You were 15 4 years ago.
Yo,
I'm old, 25. It's old. I'm ancient.
Wow. Wow. This hole is for me? Yeah. Wait, if you're in hunger,
yo. Dude, I'm sorry. I like can't make this even remotely entertaining.
Oh, that's awesome. I played this on a loop for hours as background
noise. We have to watch that together. What? With you in my lap?
My arms wrapped around you? Okay, got you.
They literally just do
Yeah, and since you like it so much, I'll allow you rub your
crotch on my leg. Haha. Oh my god.
This is uh this is signal-less music like signal-less beat. I
love signal-less
Your hunger 2 OST. I'm not putting my soul into this. I can't
do it. Can't do it. Can't do it. Degenerate DMs, no thank you.
No thank you.
Very disgusting people. Okay, now those are the messages in order,
I think.
Wait, but did I did I miss some? Hold on. Hold on.
Did I I didn't miss some, did I? Oh, I did miss some. What the
Oh right, hold on. I didn't do the ones from the next day. Why?
There are some from
There are some from September
that are out of order.
Okay, so then there's Food Shop sending these pictures to the
person. Now,
spoiler alert, this is not safe for life. Not safe for life.
Okay, we got these pictures coming out. I'll try to cover my
eyes. I saw the first one. And then we've got this picture as
well.
Now, can somebody tell me, was this sent censored or uncensored?
What is Are these censored added a Go ahead.
Uh that was uncensored.
Okay, so somebody else has censored this. Very disgusting. I
have censored this. Yes.
Gross. Gross. Gross. >> Shop's OnlyFans?
Did you know they had an OnlyFans?
I did a um I did a OnlyFans review segment for Food Shop's. I've
done two OnlyFans reviews on YouTube. One for Bob Blacks, one
for Food Shop's.
Absolutely disgusting. True. True. So, I sent you that documentary.
That has a bunch of clips uh that they've compiled. Uh it basically
shows Food Shop's lying about being prescribed POCD, lying about
being prescribed by a therapist to jerk off to lolly. So, they've
lied at that.
the Resi clips, his original stream is gone. The only way to
watch uh his call with Food Shop's is through clips. The best
way to do that is probably through a Queenman stream. And then
Kilotonics asks, "Who is better?" Uh it's a tough race. It's
a tough race that I'd have to ponder. But if you gun to my head,
I have to answer right now, honestly probably Food Shop's. Bob
Blacks is is really disgusting. So, it's not that Food Shop's
is better, it's that one of them is is you know it looks really
bad, but
Wow. Absolutely horrific stuff, bro. Absolutely horrific stuff.
True. Also, I don't know if um let me know if the YouTube clip
that I sent you works. If not, I might have to clip it myself
and then send you like an MP4 or
Oh, sure. Sure. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Give me a second. We're still
We're still looking around. Okay.
All right, I'm getting I'm getting a lot of these links in. We're
getting a lot of these links in. Okay. Yeah, we watched Thank
you. Dickers sent me the mister girl thing as well. Okay, we
we actually should probably keep watching Food Shop's stream,
her ranting about Dan here. Okay. We should continue to watch
the the Dan ranting stuff because
we do want to mix this up. Okay, we want to mix in some of the
clips every once in a while. He still doesn't Oh right, right,
right. That I was just going to point out. Obviously, um there
appears to be some lolly Okay. Oh wait, the tags are there.
Okay, it doesn't say doesn't seem to say lolly in the tags.
Sure, it looks like young kids in it, but does not say I don't
see lolly in the tags, so hey. Benefit of the doubt until seen
otherwise. >> I think all of their concerns are validated,
okay? There's a reason why >> Oh, uh Oh, happy birthday
to Dickers, apparently. Dickers, is it your birthday? Happy birthday,
buddy. Um yeah, happy birthday. I think that all the DGGers who
um were fighting against Dan, I think all of their concerns are
validated, okay? There's a reason why Dan was doing a 1v20, okay?
It isn't because Dan is the gigachad that's like trying to do
the 1v20 martial arts thing. Fighting against 20 people? What
was Dan
What was Dan fighting with people over? What is she talking about
here? Was Dan fighting with like members of Food Shop's server
to argue that she's a lollycon or Oh, Dickers is old, eh? Damn,
33.
You look great for 33 though, okay? I'm going to say it. I'll
say it. 33, I wouldn't put you a day over 31.
You're looking great for 33. Okay. What Does anybody Oh, the
DGG Olympics. Wait, was this Was this Hold on. Give me a second.
Over the DGG Olympics. Okay, he was arguing with people, but
was it about calling Food Shop's a Was it just over the DGG Olympics
in general? Something to do with DGG.
I'm curious. thing, okay? It's because Dan is just wrong.
And everybody else is trying to point out how wrong he is, but
he just won't back down, okay? That's literally it. Okay? Sure.
Sometimes when you're getting dog piled, you think that you're
the right one, okay? And sometimes when you're getting dog piled,
sometimes you're the Okay, in this case, he's always the right
when he when he's getting dog piled, okay? I'm just saying. So,
is the context
Is the context clear?
Now, here's the thing. Okay, Dan.
I think
that this is gay, okay? I think this is gay and Okay, you're
looking well. Thank you, Rex. Okay. I think this is gay and I
for one do not enjoy this, okay? I'm only doing this because
I view this as a necessity because I know Dan's character, okay?
And honestly, if I monetize
this You know what? I'm all for it. Do you know why? It's because
I think that if I have to suffer, I think I should at least make
money suffering, okay? Because ain't no way you're going to get
me to suffer for free, okay? Ain't no way you're going to get
me to suffer for free. There's no way you're doing that to me,
okay? So, you know what? Very interesting. >> Yeah, I am
going to stream this, okay?
Now, with that being said,
with that being
I mean, I Listen, nothing Food Shop's has said in this stream
is anywhere near as bad as her wishing like harm and and validating
the harm, saying Kiwi Farms is totally justified in doxxing and
swatting Dan and his family. That was crazy, okay? That's a totally
crazy thing to say. Nothing she said this time has been anywhere
near that
Although, I don't I don't know exactly why she thought that was
a good thing to do, but he said. Again, all right. All I'm asking
from Dan
is to not call me any child-related
crazy when I'm trying to defend your friend, okay? I'm trying
to defend your friend Destiny, okay?
Dan, it's really inconvenient for you to point point out all
these child things about me, okay? My child attractions. Really
inconvenient when I'm trying to defend your friend from allegations
of
>> You can't make it up, okay? Listen, I can't defend your
friend over his allegations that he's hoarding if you call me
a Okay, regardless of how true it is, I cannot do that. Please
stop. Think of Think of what you're doing.
Okay? Yes, I criticize you. Yes, I'm very very harsh against
you and your character. But notice, before all of this, I did
not go after your family. I did not go after your kids. I did
not go after your wife. I did not go after
Oh, wait. Is she lying? Is she just
Hold on.
Wait, from from the days before this, we have those clips. What
the hell? Wait, where did those clips come from then?
Wait, is this like AI? Hold on. Do we need to watch this again?
Good for him. My boy.
Probably got arrested again. Okay. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Where was this?
Just remember every single battle I pick is justified, okay?
Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Sorry, I skipped way too
far forward. >> Food Shop's is wrong. About what? So, that's
kind of expected.
Hey, why is Why is Dan here spinning here? This is 2 days ago.
And that's why I criticize his parenting, okay?
So, first she criticizes his parenting, which I would say is
not the same as going after kids, okay? You stop there, then
it's not the same as going after his kids. That's why I think
it's a reasonable escalation, okay? That's why I think it's a
reasonable escalation,
I hope that your wife gets harassed more at work, okay? So, that
of course is a reference to Kiwi Farmers and not just Kiwi Farmers,
but Gato Fumador, okay? The the H3 snark adjacent guy. Everybody
trying to dox Dan's wife, say call Dan's wife at work, right?
That's an insane escalation. Dan's done nothing close to that.
Jesus.
Oh, is there still in here? He's been He's been in here.
He's [__] mad.
So, Dan says pet should Food Shop's Anyway, who cares? And Food
Shop's says, "Huh, it's really cool that Kiwi Farms doxxed your
wife and tried to call her at work."
Amazing stuff. Good for him. My boy.
Probably got arrested again.
Probably in some girl drama again. Okay. I hear that's been happening.
Yeah?
It's rare. All right, I'll speed it up. Wait. Wait. Wait. We're
speeding up. Every single battle I pick is justified, okay? Just
want Just in case anyone wonders if I'm being unhinged. Uh-huh.
>> All right, well. Love you guys and uh stay safe. Be
All right, see you then.
Uh no, by by the way, got to sting that nobody gave a [__]
about that comment. There wasn't a single person there who was
like, "No, don't say that about Food Chops. Food Chops isn't
a pedo."
Notice that? Notice that how she defends Destiny no matter what.
He didn't say Nobody else there wanted to go, "No, Food Chops
No way."
You can't call Food Chops a pedo. That's crazy, dude. There's
no way you could call her that. Get out of here, man. Didn't
happen.
Okay, a little bit later in the stream.
Well, what can you do? Haters going to hate, okay?
They hate us cuz they ain't us. True.
Holy Very cool stuff.
Bro, he called me a pedo. Yeah, of course I don't want to feel
bad for him anymore. Yeah, or for his wife, or for his kids.
What the Of course I hope they get harassed more.
So, just to be clear, that's very different, right? Those are
very different things. Going from I don't care about him or his
wife or whatever to I hope they get harassed more. That's very
different, okay? Morning Take End, how's it going?
But wait, but wait, if you thought that's where it got bad, just
wait. There's more. There's more. Yeah. I hope he I hope he gets
stocks. I hope he gets swatted. You know, I don't care anymore.
That seems totally That seems like totally fair for an offhanded
comment that nobody even felt the need to push back on.
For you to go, "Oh yeah, every one of those Kiwi Farmer tactics
I've been saying are evil and life destroying? Yeah, we should
do all of them to Dan right now."
I thought I thought I thought Dan was a victim. I thought Destiny
was a victim. What the [__] man? All right.
Cool. Oh boy. Oh boy. She's about to realize how quick reality
flips, okay?
You go You have to go You go after certain people in that community,
reality just goes upside down. All the things you were arguing
before and everybody's like, "You're correct. You're correct.
You're correct." All that's going to change.
That'll change real fast, all right? >> You as a person,
as an individual >> No, hold on. But notice before all
of this, I did not go after your family. I did not go after your
kids. I did not go after your wife. I did not go after you as
a person, as an individual in the sense of you being a creepy
predator person, okay? How
Okay, so maybe it's possible that they mean before Not today,
but before Dan called them a pedo.
But then I I'm sorry, but you're just saying, "Okay, I can just
say I can do whatever I want. I can advocate for you being getting
doxxed and swatted if you call me a pedo." I feel like the appropriate
response,
You want to use the Destiny-ism,
the tit-for-tat in this situation would be just calling him a
pedo back. In which case, I'm pretty sure he would just go, "Oh
yeah, turnabouts fair play." Move on. >> ever. However,
the moment you take apart that bar, it's just all-out war. Yeah,
no, it's it's got to hurt, Riles. Got to hurt, okay? When when
he's when Destiny's sitting there and he doesn't even notice
that Dan just called Food Chops a pedo. Doesn't care.
Right? Food Chops literally going
as hard as she can to defend Destiny.
Lying as much as she has to. Whatever she can do, she'll do to
defend Destiny and Dan's like, "This person's a pedo." And Destiny's
just like, "Mhm."
Her, yeah. Anything else, man? >> or and it's nasty and
it's bad for everyone, okay?
But here's the thing, okay? You didn't want to de-escalate and
now we're here,
>> Yeah, Destiny is going to love this. Destiny needed
a convenient way to ditch the pedo. I I think he'll, you know,
he'll do his normal avoiding thing. He'll let it go for a while.
I don't think he'll ever totally abandon Food Chops. He'll go
on Food Chops' stream and stuff. He'll make it seem like he's
supporting Food Chops,
Needs them to continue doing their work. >> Adult decisions,
adult consequences, all right? Yes? Push, pull. You are in your
40s. You need to figure this out, okay? You're like twice my
age. Twice. You're twice my age, bro. You're like 50% more of
my age or some [__] all right? No, you're you're
almost you're almost twice my age. There's no excuse for any
of this immaturity, okay? There's just no excuse, all right?
Oh, there's no excuse for calling me a pedo while There's no
excuse for this immaturity.
Hold on. Ho- ho- hold on.
Wait, we need some uh we need some clips
What do we got?
What do we got? We have this one. What is this one?
I like femininity.
But do you like it more or less than like masculinity? I want
a cute little girl that I can wrap my arms around. So, you like
being like in the dominant role? Yes.
Like a partner? Cool. Now, on on its own, not damning, okay?
On its own, not damning. Weird, given some of the other
Right? Cuz that makes it physical, that makes it real, makes
it in the real world. But hold on. I'm in I'm only into the most
feminine of the most feminine. That's what I'm Wait, what does
that mean? I need to I need to have a little girl to wrap myself
around. Oh, like you're like
big spoon is what you're saying.
Oh, I get you. >> I need to have like a 12-year-old. Just
in case you actually thought for a second, "Oh, this is just
like big little stuff. That's totally normal."
No. I'm in I'm I'm No. No. No. No.
Oh boy. All right, that's
Yikes. What do you want to call them a pedo? Okay, that would
be really If you guys called
this person a pedo for some reason after these comments, that
would be really
Okay? Really [__] inappropriate.
Wait, what is this? Oh, this is the songs, right? Right, right.
We had the songs before.
We We can give this one one more listen.
If you believe that,
I'll wrap you.
You know why? Cuz Cuz I'm You goddamn Right. I'm a literal
Now, of course, this could just be satire, right? This could
just be satire. But I think with some of the comments they've
made, some of the things they've said, we'll get to the therapy
discussions a little bit later.
I don't know if you can just discount this stuff. It's like it's
getting to the point where it's like, "Oh, this is very weird.
You're like flirting with this stuff in a way
Are Are you flirting with it? Is it
Oh boy. It's a legally valid confession thinly hiding between
the song cover.
I don't know about that, but man, I'm I'm getting close to I'm
just about there, okay?
Really makes you think. Yeah, I mean
Oh man.
That's some some yikesy stuff. I'm just going to say it. It's
some There's some yikesy stuff going on here, okay?
okay, I've got I've got the next part, but we should keep watching
Food Chops, all right? We We want to intersperse some of these
clips just just in case they want to react, we should intersperse
some of the clips so they have to dodge around the actual reason
somebody would call them a pedo. >> how I No, you're almost
twice my age. There's no excuse for You're almost twice my age.
How dare you see these clips and call me a pedo, Dan? It's It's
crazy. It's unhinged.
That's like saying Destiny's pretending to be because he confessed
to it multiple times. It's unhinged. >> any of this immaturity,
okay? There's just Sorry, I For the sake of the DGGers who might
watch this via Food Chops' stream, I should probably avoid mentioning
Destiny just so they don't have their brains shut off. Okay?
I'll I'll avoid it for the rest of the time just so you guys
can actually understand the example. >> all right? You're
It's crazy how immature you are. Like I'm actually flabbergasted.
I'm like I don't know. Like I think it's crazy to me, okay? Like
at the very least, I don't know. I don't know how you let a trans
girl get more like mature than you or some [__] like
that, but that's crazy, okay? Dog, you need to go through puberty
again. I'm just saying, all right? Like maybe your balls haven't
dropped. Like
>> Like I'm just saying, okay? >> drink a martini,
shaken not stirred. Say no, man.
Yo, thank you so much, my dude. Thank you so much for the five.
Australian, thank you. Um but yeah. Uh there you go. That's the
drama. That's the stupid [__] And I um and I'm
What? Is that it? That's it.
Oh my goodness.
I'm I'm shocked. Has anybody been talking about on Twitter or
anything like her basically saying she thinks Dan deserves to
be doxxed and swatted?
Is there anybody talking about that on Twitter? Like I feel like
most people were just unaware of this.
Very strange things to say when apparently that's like the most
evil thing that could happen. I mean, it's not new. Hold on,
it's new for someone like Dan.
It's definitely new to say, "By the way, maybe this person just
doesn't understand like concepts or what they're saying." Like
right? They clearly can't attach like concept
like I was going to say conceptual things, but concepts in their
head. They can't attach them to like words and express themselves
very Which, you know, in some cases I'm sympathetic. Pot calling
the kettle black, but in other in other cases, okay? I always
know the direction I'm going in an abstract way. I just sometimes
have aphasia. I like lose words. Okay, this person just doesn't
understand how to
like reason with abstract concepts at all. So, I feel like when
they say something like, "Oh, Dan deserves to be doxxed and swatted
and his wife deserves to be harassed." They don't connect that
to like the other arguments they've made or anything else they've
said in the past. They just say something emotional in the moment
that they think sounds vaguely Destiny-coded.
And then they they don't like ponder the consequences of the
things they say. They don't ponder any of the implications of
the things they say. They just say them and then they deal with
it as it goes, right? That's like their life. They They're just
tumbling through life as a
I don't know, like an input-output machine. Like the All things
they say are just a function of like
give me the nearest approximation of something Destiny would
say.
You don't have aphasia. I I know I don't. I just sometimes feel
like I do. I reach for words sometimes, okay? I reach for words.
From a 15-year-old. What is this? We got one more We got
clip here. Hold on. Have you ever heard of people sending non-consensual
or non-solicited
vag pics? What are you talking about? Okay, clearly clearly I've
never dealt with crazy 15-year-olds before like I did, >> You don't
send pictures of a 15-year-old I think that that one probably
is out of context, but we're going to laugh anyway, okay? We're
going to laugh anyway. Very funny.
Funny stuff.
I'm just going to assume I'm just going to assume that like Jstark
is going to
Jstark is going to make a [__] segment on me later
because of Dan, okay? So, I mean
No, not because of Dan, because of the [__] you said
about Dan that was totally
Yeah, do you think you could Do you think you could say you want
Dan doxxed and swatted and I wouldn't cover it? Do you think
you could do that? That's That's crazy That's like a total detachment
from reality.
I will I will say thank you to Food Shops for She actually got
away with it. She got away with saying Dan and Dan's family should
be harassed by Kiwi Farms, okay? Or at least that's the implication.
She got away with it. And then she decided to keep pressing on
it until we looked into it and somebody sent me the clips of
her saying these crazy things about his family on stream.
So, thank you Food Shops for not letting it go, deciding to press
down, and helping me look into it. I really appreciate it.
Yo, what was that? That was Spruce Willis with a gifted sub.
Thank you very much, Spruce Willis. Appreciate it, buddy. Thank
you. This is not real. This is a joke, almost certainly. Digger
says, "I spoke to her in private. She confirmed that she did
get sent pics from a 15-year-old, but the 15-year-old was trafficked,
so she's innocent." That is a joke. That is comparing it to the
Destiny situation. Listen, guys, you're allowed to get pictures
from a minor. You're allowed to solicit and retain that so long
as that minor is being trafficked. That makes you okay. That
makes you innocent. It's all good, okay? It's all good. >> Good
job engaging in anti-fan tactics, I guess. Like good for you.
I'm glad that you can learn something out of this entire drama.
And This is This is the only argument they have to ever defend
themselves. Oh, these people are unhinged anti-fans. Remember
what Destiny said? Remember what Destiny said about these people?
They're unhinged anti-fans. They're totally unhinged. They're
crazy.
These These unhinged anti-fans. Destiny said so. Destiny's going
to tell you guys that Dan's an unhinged anti-fan, for sure.
I don't think so. Oh, who knows though? Who knows? Guy has not
been acting rationally lately.
Again, a
>> Food Shop threatens to doxx and says she wants Dan doxxed
and swatted. She hopes Dan gets doxxed and swatted. Destiny says
he wants to doxx Wicked Supreme. This This community is just
a bunch of doxxers. It really is. They're trying to distance
themselves. The The people around Destiny are trying to distance
themselves from Food Shops, but Destiny needs her and it's a
creating just the funniest dynamic in the world. Don't we love
to see it, guys? I've I feel like we I love to see it. I don't
know about you guys. Don't forget the Discord. Oh,
I can forget about it. Listen, the cops are the ones who shouldn't
forget about it, okay? I can forget about it.
I don't have to talk about it that much. I think it's cool that
they dropped the pretense that they ever actually cared about
doxxing. I mean, was the Was the pretense even there to begin
with? Bad Empanada I mean, under their worldview, under their
their exact standard, yes, Bad Empanada has done nothing wrong
under their exact